anxiety for me I've learned is is a
feeling that now has a word Zayn Malik
is a Nick is opening up publicly for the
first time in six years since I've had
my daughter and since she was born like
the main thing in my mind is like trying
to be a good example to her he joined
Alex Cooper for the latest episode of
caller Daddy and broke his silence on
its mom Yolanda my most valuable thing
that I have in life is time and that
takes so much time in in a toxic
environment to like explain yourself to
people and justify this and so I just
kind of keep to myself I knew what the
situation was I knew what happened
um and the people involved knew what
happened too I just wasn't trying to get
into a negative back and forth with her
any sort of narrative online where my
daughter was going to look back and read
that this
heard with his two year order Kai okay
who he shares with Gigi she loves Disney
movies so we've seen a lot of Disney
songs together nursing like You've Got a
Friend in Me and stuff she just looks
really cute and of course he spoke out
about his exit from One Direction so I
just got ahead of the curve if I'm being
honest with you I was like I'm just
gonna get out of here I think this is
done and I just seen it
um and I completely selfishly wanted to
be the first person to go and make my
own record we've been together every day
for five years and we got sick of each
other for being completely honest
um
and saying that I deserve to be smacked
security was doing their job and
protecting their client Britney Spears
is speaking out about her recent Las
Vegas incident with NBA player Victor
wenbauma's security guard on my way into
the place actually I was knocked down by
like three 12 year olds trying to get my
picture my security not one time touched
them or even came near them
um point being is
um I didn't appreciate the people saying
that I deserve to be here because no
woman ever deserves to be hit Spears
claims that she tapped the NBA player on
the back that was backhanded hit my face
it came back on the floor my best friend
picked me up and held me and I did get
an apology I'm at my table
30 minutes later but I have yet to
receive a public apology